[Music]
reviewing the Intel Arc a770 video card
it is the limited edition 16 gigabyte
card not actually limited small asterisk
there and the best way to summarize the
impending review you're going to watch
is Big oof it's because the a770 still
has basically all of the driver problems
that the arc A380 had that we reviewed
except the A380 wasn't really supposed
to exist as a standalone card it was
just supposed to be in OEM systems in a
couple of places in Asia and it's a
little bit different when you roll
something out that's far more expensive
it's intended for Standalone system use
and it still has all the driver problems
so that's part of what we're talking
about today now one of the other
interesting aspects here is that Intel
is competing on price so they are only
talking about Nvidia in any of their
presentation slides ignoring any of
these existence that is because AMD also
competes on price and video doesn't do
this they compete on quality and they
charge whatever the hell they want
clearly so we're going to talk about
that today and going over the 350 16
gigabyte a770 as it relates to things
like 240 250 cards that are sometimes
better before that this video is brought
to you by the height y60 the height y60
is one of the most unique cases to
launch anytime recently coming in
multiple color options like this bright
red and it's also built for both water
Cooling and Air cooling the case pays
extreme attention to detail particularly
with cable management paths like you can
see with the quality rubber grommets
that are always passed through and with
split lower and upper chambers learn
more at the link in the description
below okay so it was chaos working on
this review it's really not
straightforward with the Intel art cards
and that's because of the driver issues
and stuff as simple as monitors just not
getting display when you plug them in
sometimes so not the easiest card to
work with for benchmarking which already
means we're not really going to
recommend it to a wide audience maybe an
Enthusiast audience that's more willing
to deal with troubleshooting and being
the best data tester and we talked about
this with the A380 where Intel needs to
pick up some initial users to start
rolling and get the drivers working so
it is a chicken or the egg problem it's
just that you don't want to be I don't
know if it's the egg or the chicken you
don't want to be the
you don't want to be the one that has to
do all the driver research I don't know
this doesn't work with chicken or the
egg anymore you don't want to be the
beta tester so sometimes this card looks
pretty good we'll look at that but for
the most part things like the AMD RX
6600 the rx6600 XT they put up a really
strong fight it's against Nvidia where
Intel does look good and that makes
sense because again they don't really
seem to care about
price they just charge whatever and then
people buy it but we need to talk about
pricing first then we'll get into the
drivers and then performance we put
together a really simple just list of
cards really for our own reference and
we'll show that on the screen but just
averaging three random cards on NewEgg
and Amazon in the US versus the MSRP for
stuff that's out now we saw that these
days the RX 6600xt it's about 323
dollars averaged it's launch MSRP was
380. so that makes it a direct
competitor to the a770 8 and a 16
gigabyte the eight gigabyte model the
a770 is 330 dollars the a750 will review
soon that'll be a separate video that's
290 Intel has a better chance there for
a value argument and then for other AMD
competition the most obvious would be
the RX 6600 that's a hundred dollars
cheaper than the a770 at about 248
average across just three random ones
right now got some Nvidia prices on
there as well the 3060 is probably the
closest comparison that Intel goes up
against and to be clear the average
prices we pulled those are for new inbox
cards available at retail not like eBay
or something just before any of these
companies try to complain about that and
claim that it was second hand it's not
that's new in box so a driver's still
bad let's start here last time with the
A380 we talked about how one of our
monitors did not work with the A380 and
it was just a black screen and we also
showed a clip of how the screen was
sized like like basically
four inches by three inches on the 28
inch display and that's what we had to
work with now it's gotten worse we have
three monitors we have now tested we
decided to cycle a bunch of monitors
through just because we knew these were
problematic already and so thought we'd
validate it there's three we have here
at least so we don't have that many
different types that just either had a
black screen so no display out or they
were fixable but they were black screen
up until you could Boot and get the
drivers installed if you ask well how do
you get the drivers installed if you
can't see it's easy for us because we
have a lab full of stuff we can do
whatever we want but if you're an end
user you buy this card and that's your
display device and you don't have an igp
or Onboard video anything like that uh
you're kind of screwed so we had
problems with drivers uh there's no fan
control so that's really frustrating we
had to get a beta version of the arc
control package to control the fans
on the video card that is being sold at
retail to actual customers
that's right this will be available at
retail in one week on October 12th and
you cannot change the speed of the fans
After Burner doesn't read it doesn't
know what to do with it Precision
obviously doesn't work rip and Intel art
control doesn't work either in fact it's
not even an option in our control they
had to give us a special version that
will eventually go out so it's this is
an incomplete product we are reviewing a
product that is not finished we don't
generally like doing that because it
doesn't turn out well for the product
even if it will eventually be good crtx
20 series our tax games and ship for 55
days we told everyone just buy a 10
series card additional problems uh so
some games are broken here's a list this
is actually from Intel's own patch notes
to us and they these are the ones that
they mostly fixed with a driver update
here in the final days before the
reviews went up but we ran into other
issues still and DirectX 11 with Rainbow
Six Siege is one of them you'll see that
later we've also noticed that the fans
always spin and it's because of either
the soc temperature or the idle load or
something but uh they were off when we
first powered it on we installed the
drivers and then they didn't stop
spinning that was true on now four
different test benches with two
different operating systems and three
different motherboards types so they're
not supposed to do that but they do and
that's just the tagline for the arc uh
next thing the Arca overlay is still
really obnoxious to interact with it's
still an overlay so it's like the steam
overlay except your entire screen at
desktop so even though the actual Arc
control window takes up this amount of
space on your screen that is this amount
of space you can't do anything with the
rest of the screen like take notes or
write down things that you want to tweak
or tune or overclock or whatever because
it is a complete overlay additionally
when we opened our control the first
time on two task benches it opened with
three errors in the top right corner
great start Intel thank you Papa
yeah yeah we had other driver and
control package issues too but we'll
talk about those in a separate video we
wanted the front load at least these
notes because it really sets the stage
for what is it why why is the price so
good compared to say Nvidia if you
ignore any of these existence that's why
that's the answer wanting to get that
out there early because the reality of
all of this is the performance is kind
of irrelevant if any of the things that
we just stated will really annoy you
about this product you just don't buy it
at that point because just like we said
with the RTX series you you we don't
review the future our job is to review
what is this going to be like when it
goes through its own AMD Renaissance of
driver updates like AMD did with
adrenaline or whatever it was so uh
that's what you need to know that means
this is going to be an incredibly
frustrating card at some point at least
if you are not an experienced user or
you're recommending a card more likely
for an inexperienced user so those are
the people who definitely should not be
Buy in an art guard period and we'll
talk about the 750 later but enough of
all that let's get into some of the
testing GPU thermals will start us off
for this we use a custom benchmarking
scene to load the GPU with a consistent
and sustained gaming workload this is
with full auto settings for the card so
it's as it performs out of the box
Intel's V bios will set a temperature
Target and make the fans follow that
Target which means we also need noise
tests and we have those to evaluate
whether Intel can design a cooler and V
bios competently enough to handle a 200
plus watt card here's the chart the a770
GPU took about 380 seconds or maybe six
minutes or so to hit steady state and
level out at 72 degrees Celsius for the
core temperature it occasionally
dithered but mostly stayed at 72 degrees
now whether Intel is exposing GPU Edge
or something more similar to nvidia's
numbers isn't really detailed yet so we
can't compare these numbers like for
like with AMD or with Nvidia directly
but we can make judgments based on
Intel's own clock behavior and against
board Partners as they launch if if they
ever launch the memory thermals reported
by software logs about 80 degrees
Celsius so that's acceptable for gddr6
and no problem there we'll wire this up
separately for a more in-depth analysis
of the thermal mechanical stuff in the
future but from initial numbers it does
look acceptable the power density is low
enough that this cooler can handle it on
its Auto settings so that's overall good
as well and that's important because
Intel doesn't really have much in the
way of board Partners right now although
we hear EVGA might be available of
course none of that actually means
anything in a vacuum it's just a
temperature number so we need to
understand the noise levels and for that
we need to understand the fan speed
here's that chart we just looked at
except now we're adding the RPM to the
right Axis the a770 started out where it
was idling for us most times which is
about 550 RPM or so it's inaudible
though as soon as the workload started
the fan instantaneously wrapped there
isn't much hysteresis on load start and
the the fan wraps to the peak of its
default curve at the same time as steady
state levels out for thermals not
surprising we suspect V bios is setting
that the fan will follow so a hotter
case or higher ambient will run a higher
RPM and therefore higher noise for this
car speed levels out at 1800 RPM in our
test environment which ends up averaging
17.50 or so we'd normally do noise level
testing and five percent increments for
fan speed and while Intel did eventually
provide special tools for this it came
in too late for the review and it's a
special tool so at some level it sort of
doesn't matter anyway because users
can't control it the left column of this
very simple table shows the status of
the card during the data logging period
at idle and fan RPM at 540 the noise
level was undetectable it was at the
limit where our room noise level was the
same and therefore there's no data to be
had here from idle with this card our
room noise floor is 26 DBA so in those
conditions it's functionally silent at
70c and 30 seconds into our workload the
card ramps to 1400 RPM and total noise
climbs to 34 4.4 DBA as a result at 20
inches distance this is with all other
system fans off so the GPU fan is the
only thing producing noise not only on
the system but in the room this trend
continued to go into 36.2 at 1500 RPM 37
a little above that and peaking at about
38 DBA that's fine we don't have any
major complaints about that because we
found most aib Partners tune their
temperature Target and fan curve to land
them in the 38 to 40 DBA range in our
test environment so this is in line with
everyone else Intel has at least done
well in this regard it'd be better if
users could control the fan as there's
Headroom to back off the fan speed and
ultimately this design is not
sophisticated and partners will be able
to do better probably for the same price
but we'll revisit that as it becomes
more relevant for now it's the only a770
we've actually seen so that's all we can
really base it on for power tests we'll
look at that in the near future and with
the a750 we'll look at it as well but
for now let's move on to flatness we
have a teardown that's coming up you'll
really want to see that by the way so we
tested the flatness of the contact plate
on the vapor chamber for the cooler this
is just something we do for video cards
to see what is the quality of Machining
they're doing to make sure there's a
good contact patch and then we'll get
into some of the other stuff we have a
whole separate mechanical discussion we
want to do but for the results here it
ended up being overall okay it wasn't as
impressive as most of the 30 series
cards that we tested however versus say
the 3080 you can see that the median box
and the box and whisker plot for the
a770 is much better than the 3080 Fe was
and all that really means is that the
point-to-point depth is relatively
consistent across the plate of the vapor
Chambers that's a good thing it's a good
start on the Machining side the build is
a nightmare for a different reason but
the machine on the contact plate was
overall good and thermals so far are
mostly in control okay on to the game
testing Total War Warhammer 3 is up
first so this is tested with dx11 and
the battle Benchmark it's also one of
the best case scenarios for the arc a770
it will only get worse from here but
we're going to start on a strong foot
for Intel the a770 16 gigabyte card ran
at 90 FPS here with lowest space
proportionally to that average that's a
better thing than it normally would be
just because Intel is still relatively
new here it has dx11 weaknesses and it
has driver problems so frame time
consistency is not a given with Intel
but it's still expected that allows it
to perform roughly equivalently to its
direct price competitor from Nvidia the
RTX 3060 which is currently a little
more expensive the a770 is also about
equal to the RTX 2070 so clearly no
point upgrading if you're on that or
better and it's about 12 percent ahead
of the 6600 XT currently in the 300 to
330 dollar price range the rx6700 XT
manages to outperform the a770 by 26
percent while selling for nine percent
more money on Amazon right now that's a
great deal for AMD and frankly you'd be
better off going that route in this test
at least their driver problems have
gotten smaller over the years before
moving on we'll point out the RTA X 3050
and a 300 option on Amazon that's
allowing the a770 it's around at 45
ahead for about 17 percent of more money
comparatively that's the better option
than the 3050 if you can stretch the 50
bucks for the a770 although the 6600 XT
is also worth considering 1440p gives us
an idea for scaling with the same game
settings the 6700 XT maintains a 17 lead
over the a770 here dropping pretty hard
from its previous 26 lead the a770 is
still about the same as an RTX 3060 with
the lead over the 3050 climbing to 53
percent from 45 percent Intel has a big
architectural Advantage as resolution
increases or you might be able to
rephrase it as it has a disadvantage as
resolution decreases this is something
we observed in our A380 previous preview
as well now we get into some of the
games where it tips a little bit worse
for Intel in F1 2022 with dx12 the Intel
a770 ran at 106 FPS average with lows at
63 and 60 FPS that has it behind the RX
6600 non-xt a far cheaper card at about
250 bucks when we checked before filming
versus the 350 MSRP if it hits that of
Intel's card while holding a 13 lead
that's a rough position for Intel to be
in sure versus the 378. 3060 which has a
14 lead over Intel the value looks
better it's at least competitive in that
comparison but we can't let Intel
manipulate the story into it just being
Nvidia versus Intel there is another
player and it is AMD and in reality AMD
holds the same defender's Advantage as
Nvidia does where it's already got all
these drivers and it's been through
these problems before so Intel in this
chart is losing for Value when you look
at AMD because AMD also competes on
price and Intel is not good enough to
just be better value than on video when
you have a third competitor that's why
it's so cool that there's three of them
now because this starts to happen where
they actually need to plan against a
third player in the market so also the
6600 XT doesn't help Intel's case either
at 145 FPS average to Intel's 106 it's
becoming noticeable especially when you
remember that this additional processing
Headroom on the 6600 XT can be
reassigned to higher graphic settings or
resolutions you can get something for it
the 6600 XT is 37 lead is in exchange
for less money at 323 dollars the a770
has about the same performance as the
RTX 2060 KO it outperforms the RTX 3050
by 14 and it offers a boost over the RX
580 of about 59 just for something older
to give you an anchor point at 1440p the
a770 ends up at 88 FPS average once
again tying the RTX 3060 and RTX 2070
but allowing the 6700xc an
embarrassingly strong lead at 53 ahead
compared to lower end options the a770
leads the RTX 3050 by 20 FPS or about 30
percent establishing a better position
than it had at 1080p if intel can ship
big gpus at some point this architecture
May really benefit it at 4K resolutions
and at the high end or the more
expensive class of cart assuming at
least the architecture stretches that
large if you were to upgrade to the a770
something like the RX 580 and Below
might make sense to move from but these
AMD options are looking a lot fiercer
than they did just a couple weeks ago
moving to 4K with F1 still the a770
maintains a playable frame rate at about
60 FPS average although it's one percent
lows are dipping but still playable the
a770 pulls ahead of the 2070 the 3060
alike finally we're missing the 6700 XT
on this chart simply because we didn't
have time to go back for it and run it
again but it'd still be ahead we're just
not sure how that percentage Advantage
would change shadow of the Tomb Raider
is next another dx12 game this one has
the a770 at 117 FPS average with lows
appropriately based for the average FPS
again that's a good thing when it's not
necessarily a given and with Intel it's
not at least not yet the 3060 leads the
a770 marginally and by an amount that
isn't noticeable to a player and given
the price hike it's not worth it at
least in this game the RX 6600 though
embarrasses the a770. it's eight percent
better and it's somewhere in the range
of a hundred dollars cheaper or
approaching it the 6600 XT pushes that
to 26 percent better while still being
cheaper at 1440p the a770 is still
roughly tied with the RTX 2070 and RTX
3060 but the rx6600 now Falls below the
a770 that's good for Intel and again it
reinforces its higher resolution
strengths the 6600 XT leads the a770 by
10 now down from its 26 lead prior so
the rk770 the art cards in general as
you'll see it does better at 1440p and
at 4K and phrased another way Intel has
maybe a 1080 P problem or you could say
the AMD series cards have a 4K problem
Nvidia seems a little more balanced now
that we have the context of both of
these together it's still not
establishing a value lead over AMD at
1440p however the Gap is at least
closing in Intel's favor with this
resolution increase it's also easier to
justify the value versus an RTX 3060 in
these charts which explains why Intel
has focused so much of its marketing
energy against that card specifically
and now at 4K the a770 maintains a
mostly playable frame rate and it could
be tuned while finally passing the RX
6600 XT the 3060 falls behind here
allowing the a770 elite of 16 percent
the 6700 XT keeps the lead but also is
reduced and now at a 28 Advantage once
again we see the same thing where AMD
has its known 1080p advantages Intel has
these Newfound 4K 1440 advantages we
talked about the A380 in a preliminary
sense and because they are going in sort
of two opposite directions they're
they're diverging as the resolution gets
the lower the upper bound of our testing
which depend where you play for
resolution there's a clear benefit to
one of those two vendors Rainbow Six
Siege is up now and this one is brutal
for Intel it's on dx11 here most
immediately we need to point out the
A380 in this most recent round of
testing where we collected all fresh
data new operating system we used a
different A380 it's still a gunnier card
but it's a different specific unit we
also have a new version of Rainbow Six
Siege but we're using the same graphic
settings resolution all that stuff we
noticed performance Decay only in this
title on the A380 and simultaneously we
noticed an introduction of some frame
time inconsistencies with all Arc cards
in fact all all of the art cards both of
them on this chart did very poorly here
we ran additional test passes we
confirmed the behavior we did driver
wipes and reinstalls we use different
benches everything and currently we
think this is due to either the recent
game updates which cause issues on Arc
or due to Intel driver updates in either
case we suspect software we use dx11
last time also despite a potential
Vulcan advantage on Intel uh and it
still did better last time even with the
X11 so anyway the a770 ran 125 FPS
average here which is just a complete
failure of performance it's doing worse
than the RX 580 worse than the rx6500 XT
and worse than the GTX 1070 from six
years ago something is wrong with either
the driver package or the game but only
apparently as it relates to Intel and
it's causing this Behavior at 1440p that
Trend continues unsurprisingly the a770
performance remains broken as does the
A380 so we can move on from this game
and just mark it as bad for now maybe
it'll get better with an update to the
drivers or the game itself but this is
not a unique experience Intel sent us
that message we talked about earlier
about all kinds of broken games during
the review process and you're going to
keep you are the beta tester here so
you'll see this sometimes we'll move on
to something with Vulcan since that
should theoretically work better for
Intel than dx11 in strange Brigade The
a770 ran at 190 FPS average when I Ultra
and 1080p using the Vulcan API lows and
frame times were consistent here so
that's good and the a770 manages to
outperform the RTX 3060 by a massive 33
percent comparatively huge versus what
we saw in previous tests it's too bad
that it's just this one game but it
would change the story massively If This
Were true in more game or at least
something close to resembling maybe 50
percent even a little bit closed just
more than a one the a770 runs ahead of
the RX 6600 by 74 percent trailing only
the absolute upper end of this chart at
1440p the a770 ran at 151 FPS average
and encroached on the RTX 3070s 170 FPS
result where the 3070 led the A7 170 by
just 11 percent despite a price Gap
nearing two hundred dollars the a770
also leads the RTX 3060 once again and
the XFX RX 6600 if this scaled to all
games of course it'd be in a domineering
position against both AMD and Nvidia but
it doesn't but at least Final Fantasy
isn't too bad for it this is back on
dx11 and it's a game that's more
difficult to bind up on the GPU that
said with the class of card we're
testing today we're still GPU bound even
at 1080p up until things like the top
four cards or so on this chart the a770
ends up below the 6600 XT and the 6700
XT the former of which leads by five
percent with the latter leading by 23
percent the a770 beats the 6600 non-xt
by 10 leading the RTX 3060 by 8 this is
an example of what Intel could achieve
at a hardware level at least but that
API was Vulcan and that benefits it here
as does the way this particular game is
built so this is clearly the outlier but
it's maybe a glimpse at what Intel could
do and in that sense it's exciting at
1440p the a770 out does the 6600 XT by
15 so it's now leading where it was
marginally behind before the 6700 XT
keeps a diminished lead as does the 3070
but Intel is encroaching on both of them
older cards like the RX 580 might be
worth considering a jump from where we
see over a doubling in frame rate now at
4K the a770 now leads the 6600 XT by 29
a staggering jump that puts it in a
totally different performance class
while the 6700 XT only holds on to a 12
lead so wrapping up then first off you
jump to your jump back to at least the
driver section even if you're going to
ignore the game charts because that is
kind of like a mini conclusion in its
own so we can't recommend this card
period for the wider audience people who
don't have troubleshooting experience
people who haven't built computers
before because you are going to
encounter a problem at some point and if
you're not experienced with or or don't
like doing troubleshooting then it's not
the right fit for you and you should
just pass immediately and buy something
else AMD is in a better spot these days
than it ever has been as it's been
finally fixing driver issues that were
lying dormant for years up until the
last really couple of years so they're
looking pretty good right now that Intel
has reminded us all to appreciate and
these competing on price in terms of
performance let's say the driver stuff
doesn't bother you or maybe you get
lucky and it doesn't plague you like it
does some other people because you don't
play the right types of games to get hit
by them well uh F1 makes Intel look
really really bad here in our testing
because the 6600 XT and some of those
tests was like 37 percent better and yet
it costs thirty dollars more to buy the
Intel card which is worse uh the 6600
non-xt is 13 better in one of those F1
tests and it is 100 cheaper for the 6600
non-xt and that's with numbers we just
looked up like in the last 48 hours or
so the 30 60 in some of these tests uh
14 better 30 more so you can see where
versus the 30 60 Intel's got a better
value proposition we're not looking at
Ray tracing today we have rt tests we
want to do it's just kind of a lot to
run with the ryzen 7000 back to back but
uh RT may be something where Nvidia
holds a unique advantage over intel if
RT is something you're interested in but
we don't have that data for you today
you'll have to get it somewhere else or
come back here at a couple a couple days
or a week when we have it uh Final
Fantasy 14 on the positive side as well
as strange Brigade are both examples of
what the a770 could be if they're able
to get more Universal good performance
and stability across all the games so
that's where Oriental needs to be it
looks great in those two scenarios very
competitive really good value judgment
for the a770 those games it's just that
it's not consistent and that's the
biggest problem with the Intel art cards
right now is inconsistency so if you
look here's a bias disclosure for you I
buy based on consistency this applies to
basically everything where what I'm
trying to get is a product where I know
I can predict the performance one day to
the next uh whether it's like technology
or something mechanical like an actual
physical tool that you use and so for me
as a reviewer my bias is will lean
towards consistency and Intel Arc is not
consistent so
clearly I'm not going to be likely to
recommend it because it's not consistent
and that's what I look forward to what
Patrick looks for on the team I'm pretty
sure that's what Mike looks for on the
team so that's how we sort of evaluate
these things ultimately the a770 just
it's really not it right now Andy's
kicking its ass in a lot of these games
uh and when it doesn't it's not worth
the trade-off anyway the a750 might look
better we do have a review in the works
it's not done yet but that'll be up
pretty soon and you'll want to check
back for the teardown as well so that's
it for this one they gotta fix the
drivers that's that's really all there
is to it it's kind of like feels like
reviewing AMD about five or six years
ago where we'd look at it we go this
Hardware looks really promising from
these two games where it really did well
outperformed Nvidia was cheaper whatever
but then it just didn't work half the
time it made the screen turn funny
colors and the monitors weren't
connected it's the same stuff with Intel
so we're back in a circle it's a
different vendor uh hopefully that means
that in a couple years Intel will be
competing the same way AMD is today but
that's it for this one thanks for
watching subscribe for more check back
for the a750 review it's cheaper so that
might help outweigh some of the driver
stuff and uh you can go to
store.camersaccess.net to grab a toolkit
or a mod mat and help us out directly
we'll see you all next time